hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy we
have a very exciting guest today we have
tabitha ross pro a 2020 national teacher
of the year so if you have
questions for what it's like to be a
teacher especially a teacher of early
learners start putting them on the
message boards on facebook and youtube
but before we jump into what promises to
be a really fun conversation i'll make
my standard announcements reminder the
khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only
exist because of philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org donate i also
want to make a special shout out to
several organizations that stepped up
when they found out that we were running
at a deficit going into covet and that
deficit has only accelerated uh because
of our costs going up because of our
server costs we're trying to accelerate
a whole bunch of programs for teachers
parents and students so special thanks
to bank of america google.org att fastly
and novartis i still also want to remind
folks about uh homeroom with sal the
podcast
that's essentially
a a modified version of the live stream
kind of some of the more poignant
moments that you might find useful and
you can
you can consume it safely in your car
wherever without having to see things uh
so encourage you to go uh subscribe to
the homeroom the podcast so with that
i'm excited to have tabitha ross broy on
tabitha good to see you
hi good to see you too thanks for having
me
no it's my honor you are 2020 national
teacher of the year you're based in
kansas
so so
how did you become national teacher of
the year
you know i asked what was the process
like
so i was nominated at my district level
for state teacher of the year and you go
to a regional banquet there are four
regions in kansas and i was named one of
the finalists here in kansas and then i
was named kansas teacher of the year
shortly after that
and after that you know you submit an
application to um
ccsso the council of chief state school
officers and they have a team of 17
different organizations that pick four
finalists and i was one of those i was
really surprised when i got the phone
call because it was a washington dc
number and i thought it was a political
call you know just going into an
election year so i didn't answer at
first before i got a text message asking
me to call them back and after that we
the other three finalists who are
incredible
uh we all went to washington dc and
interviewed with those
varying education organizations we did
keynotes we interviewed with press
and just a short while later i was
selected as national teacher of the year
wow well congratulations you know i i
was lucky to see some video footage of
some of the things you do with your
students and
you know i didn't see what the other
teachers are doing but it made me pretty
convinced that you are very well
deserving of national teacher of the
year um i think we have some of this
footage if if we could take a look at it
felipe and if you could talk us through
what's going on
oh yes this is a zoom call with um a
class full of preschoolers which i'm
sure some people can identify with you
know the older kids you can't get to
talk but the younger kids you can't get
them to stop talking um so it's
incredibly
unique to be on video chat with
four-year-olds and i think at this time
i was just reading them a story about
why they couldn't be at school this was
really shortly after
um you know the school buildings had
been shut down in this shutdown in the
spring
oh and this is one of our friday dance
parties here
every friday
yes every friday we have a dance party
and other occasionally in between when
the students um you know ask for them or
we just need a break i have a disco
light that i got pretty cheap online and
we play oldies we play um things that
they like from their favorite youtube
stars and we have a great time
celebrating together
i hope to attend one day this seems like
a better party than most of the things
i'm i'm invited to
oh and here is we were releasing some of
our butterflies so this is outside of
the nursing home that my preschool is
housed inside of and what you can't see
is kind of off screen we have um some
grandma and grandpa residents um that's
what we call the volunteers who live
there watching us
release our butterflies that we watched
grow from caterpillars
wow
on here are these are my students so one
thing i really focus on in my classroom
is social emotional health and
self-regulation and those relationships
from student to student and here we are
doing an activity that builds those
relationships where they're doing a row
row your boat game they have to keep
each other safe it's playful
it's silly there's positive physical
touch and just loving interactions and
that helps them grow closer to each
other and build those super super strong
relationships
wow
no i'm i'm envious of your students i
mean i had some great teachers too but i
don't remember the dance parties or the
royal boat
simulations and the butterflies so that
that's that's incredible
and the age group you teach out there in
kansas you teach you said preschoolers
mainly four-year-olds four-year-old
preschool yeah my classroom is um funded
by the public school and special
education and at-risk dollars but yeah
we're a public school program for
four-year-olds
and what kind of gravitated you to that
age group and what do you think is kind
of the
the mindset or the special sauce that
you bring you know day in day and i'm
sure many other teachers do as well but
you know you clearly are one of those
teachers that i think these four year
olds even when they're 40 or 50 are
going to remember those those moments
what you know what what what drew you to
teaching and especially that group and
and you know how do you view it that
gives you that special pixie dust
you know when i was in high school i
knew that i wanted to help people but i
began taking a dual credit
college spanish class in which i got to
go down to the preschool um on our on
our block like in our district and teach
spanish to preschoolers and before we
started interacting with the students we
got to just observe in the classroom and
i remember this moment so clearly it was
the first time i had ever witnessed
teaching from an outsider perspective
you know i had always been on
the end of being delivered instruction
and it was the first time that i truly
saw teaching as the art form that it is
that teacher that i was watching her
name is pat walton and she is now
retired but the way that she connected
with her students that she really acted
as a guide for their learning the way
that she built relationships with them
it was magical for me to see and from
then on out i knew that i wanted to work
with kids and i knew that i wanted to
work with really young kids too
that's that's incredible there's tons of
questions coming in because i think
especially the young kid crowd my
youngest is five and a half so i won't
make too many of the questions about you
know my personal uh help that i need but
from youtube we have a question from
carys alexander
what tips do you have for older siblings
trying to help younger siblings with
tutoring and homework and distance
learning how much should we help and how
that is a great question you know i have
so many students in my class who you can
tell when they haven't had to like talk
for themselves or do things for
themselves and usually they have older
siblings so what i would do is just have
a conversation with your older kids and
talk to them about the role that they
play right so there they want to take
care of them but the best way that we
can take care of our younger siblings is
to help them learn how to do things for
themselves because we always we won't
always be there right and they need to
be able to solve problems on their own
and so you could give them a list of
things that they could do to be helpful
um including being a good role model you
know like what does it look like when
you are um doing your own work include
your younger sibling in that time but i
would just be really open with them
about that and be thankful for the
moments that they are helping because
you definitely don't want to see them go
the other way and not be interested in
that at all
but i think for sure older siblings can
be great models but um you're right on
that sometimes we give them a little bit
too much help
to help them help themselves and i've
got to believe that karis is a pretty
good older sibling the very fact that
they're asking this question shows that
they care a lot so your younger siblings
are very lucky cars
from youtube miss victoria
asks
how do you react to sassy kids the ones
that say you can't tell me what to do
etc
i've never encountered sasky kids my
kids never do anything like that but i
guess in theory other kids might so i'd
love i'd love the advice there too
you know i think that one of the first
things you have to do as the adult in
the situation is recognize your triggers
and so that definitely would have been
one of my triggers being um talked to
disrespectfully because when i was a
child
that did not fly in our house so now i
see
how that triggers me because i'm super
aware of it but what i would say is when
that happens
your
child or the child you're working with
is probably not in a state of their
brain where they can make good decisions
and be a good friend and be kind and
respectful so you're going to need to
help them sort of co-regulate in that
moment and so that means if you react
aggressively they're probably going to
react aggressively too because you know
aggression begets aggression so what
you're going to want to do is to take a
deep breath
and i just say to myself this behavior
is information right and i didn't make
that phrase up it's not unique to me but
when we view behavior as information and
not as our students or our kids
being out to get us or trying to push
our buttons then we are more likely to
be able to come up with a solution that
is helpful rather than hurtful to them
and to us and into our relationship and
so when someone says something super
sassy to me i might just take a deep
breath and give myself a second before i
respond because sometimes they are
looking for a quick response from you
but i would just say
you know you can either address that
hurtful statement you know i don't like
it when you talk that way to me if if
you want to speak to me you can use kind
words
like and give them an example or i can
tell you're really frustrated i'm going
to give you a few minutes to calm down
and then i'll come back
that's powerful advice not just for
dealing with young kids i would say any
relationship
feelings are real don't escalate
try to understand where they're coming
from
you know just just to add to that i mean
i was joking obviously i i am always
trying to navigate uh and i think you
know i fall into that trap as a parent
does if like you know your your child is
not eating or whatever and you're trying
to push them and then they they kind of
dig in their heels and i think they're
trying to push push boundaries a little
bit you know and especially if things
get really you know fall apart they're
having a tantrum or maybe you feel like
having a tantrum how do you deal with
that you know i can imagine especially
the four-year-old crowd you know
sometimes with my five-year-old he just
falls apart you know when we're trying
to put him back together how do you deal
with that
this tantrums are hard right and i like
my heart goes out to people when i see
their kids doing it in public because i
know they're so embarrassed but what you
just need to remember is you know we're
we've all been through that we've all
gone through that and if people are
judging you for when that happens then
just you can ignore them but again i
would say you remaining calm is the most
important thing in that moment so
sometimes it will look like me you know
asking a child if it's okay if i can get
hug them or hold them or or hold their
hands and just doing some deep breaths
because at that moment you can't reason
with them so they're just different
areas of your brain and usually when
they're throwing a tantrum they're in a
lower center of their brain where they
they can't reason and they're in fight
or flight mode and probably fight if
they're in that tantrum mode and so you
would just want to breathe and you
calmly breathing not engaging verbally
usually will calm the situation enough
where you can get to a point that you
can reason with that child
wow that's masterful i feel
more empowered just hearing you hearing
you say that so a lot of questions
coming in uh from youtube harsh gotham
asks
how do you feel when a small kid asks a
lot of questions how do you deal with
them what to do when a kid asks a
question and you don't know the answer
back
so this happens to me all the time i
always say you never know what you don't
know until a kid asks you to explain
something and so like our high school
mascot where i live is the vikings and
someone asked me what's a viking and i
was like how do i
how do i explain this to a child you
know what a viking is um and once
someone asked me
like what is chocolate or you know just
some like i was like i really gotta go
through this so first i would encourage
you to follow up and i think that it's
okay to admit that you don't know
something so when a student asks me a
question i and i don't know i'd be like
let's look that up together where do you
think we can find out what that is um
and you can so you can teach them how to
do those beginning steps of research but
i think also when when they ask you
something that you don't know um ask
them what they think it is and see if
you can get an explanation from there um
kind of turn it on them and maybe start
working on some of those those critical
thinking skills
it's interesting that you brought up
vikings i recently read an article that
even our perceptions of vikings you know
we imagined these
you know their vikings were definitely
from scandinavia but you know they were
the seafarers who would go and like you
know pillage coastal villages and things
like that uh but apparently uh the the
the vikings might have been different
than we imagined but anyway that's a
whole other topic
why not
yeah it's fascinating
one um question i mean this is related
to the last one but this is something i
deal with a lot at home is you know i
have three kids eleven nine and five
you're dealing with classrooms of many
four-year-olds
you know one thing that kids like to do
is they like to show
adults that they care about the things
that they've done but you know sometimes
after a long day of work and i'm sure
sometimes you're you you know you're
tired at work
you know you have five kids come at you
at the same part time and say hey miss
rosbori look at what i did look at why
did you know that this is true did you
know that the vikings never ate
chocolate you know whatever how do you
deal with that how do you triage that
inbound that i think i see a lot of
young kids like to do
oh my gosh yeah they can be exhausting i
i sometimes have bruises on my shoulders
or my legs from being tapped so hard
i didn't make a rule in my class if you
want my attention you need to say my
name um instead of tapping this card um
and then you know you just hear your
name constantly and
i you know i would just really try to
create some boundaries you know if you
know that the minute that you get home
that you're not going to be able to
handle this you can create those
boundaries with your kids and say all
right when i get home
let's do hugs high fives kisses whatever
you're used to and then i need 10
minutes and i'm going to be in this room
and i'm going to put a little stop sign
on the door and that means don't come in
and then do what you need to do um to
collect yourself to meditate to exercise
to check your emails spend a little time
by yourself because it's overwhelming
that like fatigue from you know managing
a household and managing a job and then
i would say come out and be ready to
have those discussions and if your child
is struggling with that
i sometimes give kids a notebook
um and then they can write or draw the
things they want to talk to me about and
then later when we have time i might
point to my schedule and say okay it's
time to show me the ideas that you
wanted to share at circle time
when it was everyone else's turn to talk
um so i just think creating some
routines um right might be helpful in
that situation
no it's that's super valuable i'm gonna
try to apply that the related question
from youtube deathstroke uh asks what if
a child asks a question which shouldn't
be answered at the time like adult stuff
what do you do
they do they like know but what's funny
is most of the time they don't know that
it's adult stuff and so you know
sometimes i i will even get questions in
my classroom like about religion or
about about things that aren't really my
place to comment on i mean even politics
at preschool sometimes and i try to be
just you know really neutral and i will
say you know everybody believes
different things um this is something
you might want to ask your mom and dad
about or your grandma about your
caregiver whoever they live with when
you get home and if you want me to help
you do that let's write a note to them
and know that you brought that up but if
it's something kind of inappropriate
i think that i might just say
you know what let's talk about that a
little bit later right now we're talking
about math or right now we're talking
about
letter a or something like that i just
wouldn't make a big deal about it
because once you make you know a huge
deal the other kids know that it was
something inappropriate and probably the
pattern is going to be then other kids
will ask about it too um so just try to
be chill that's what would be my advice
yeah no great advice so uh from youtube
susanna garcia dominguez asks hi tabitha
how do you teach young students to
regulate
okay
this is a great question too so i am a
huge fan of conscious discipline and if
you've never heard of that i would start
by reading the book easy to love
difficult to discipline by dr becky
bailey i'm not in any kind of like
partnership or promotion i just love
consciousness i'm writing that down let
me get some paper
what is that again easy to love
difficult to discipline it that book
changed my life and now i am a huge fan
of dr becky bailey and all the work she
does she has tons of free resources on
the conscious discipline website for
families and for teachers
and one big thing to do is
first you have to teach them sort of
what feelings are right um what's it
noticing what's it feel like when i'm
angry what's it look like when i'm sad
what is my body doing you want to work
on helping them notice things like that
about themselves and about others and a
big way that you can do that is not
using judgmental language like um
you know i like it when you're mad or i
like it when you're happy and calm i
don't like it when you're sad or angry
because feelings are okay like what's
not okay is exploding when you're angry
but it is okay to be angry your feelings
give us information we just need to
teach kids what to do we need to teach
them those replacement behaviors for
tantrums and for throwing things or
hitting or hiding things like that and
so again you want to wait until they're
calm to do the teaching you want to
model calming strategies like deep
breathing
maybe coloring a picture when you're
feeling overwhelmed or getting a hug
from a person that you love i mean i
could go on and on about this um but i
think the biggest part is letting them
know that feelings are okay
and helping them notice what feelings
look like and what to do when you're
having those feelings
really i'm i'm going to buy this book
right after uh
that's actually something i've only
recently appreciated not just with
dealing with kids but you know just
relationships in general is that you
should never question someone's feelings
feelings by definition are real
so you should never
tell someone that like they're not real
or you can't have that or you know our
perceptions of reality might be
different and people can be right or
wrong about their perceptions of reality
but the feelings are real and so yeah no
i'm definitely going to take a take a
look at that take a look at that book so
this is a question i've been getting a
lot i would love your advice because you
deal day in day in day out with with
young kids
from facebook irene is asking with the
short attention spans that younger kids
have how do you keep them engaged when
teaching online
this is so hard and i differ a lot in my
school of thought from what the the you
know the reality that many of our
schools are in right now you know i
think 5 to 10 minutes max is the
attention that you can keep online as
you can see it is a struggle
um i would say the biggest thing is to
do is to make a schedule right and one
of the big things i offer to the
families of students in my class is some
kind of first then picture schedule so
you might have a picture of first i'm
doing zoom
then i get to do a preferred activity
like play-doh or play outside and you
can draw pictures you can print pictures
from the internet if you want to find me
on social media i would be glad to share
with you resources that i have already
made for this um if you wanted to make
your life way easier
but just helping your kids understand
what the expectation is it helps them
feel safe and that helps them be able to
learn better be able to regulate their
emotions when it's not something that
they they really feel like doing but
also just to let them know hey here's
what i expect for today
um here's what you're going to do and
here's what i'm going to do i think that
really helps just having that routine
in the expectation set
no
just watching you i mean you exude like
positive energy but you seem to just
have it figured out i'm very i'm very
i'm very impressed there's a question
here i don't know if you see it
at the preschool level i can imagine to
some degree from facebook moona youssef
is asking
how do you encourage kids to report
bullying i guess we could broaden that
how you deal with bullying i'm curious
do you see bullying at that age group at
the preschool level then how do you how
do you deal with it if you do
you know i am
of the idea that you know bullying is
still a huge problem i think it's a
little more invisible than it used to be
because of because it's become more like
cyber bullying or online
but you know again i'll go back to
conscious discipline there's a great
video out on youtube about like um i
think it's called making a bully from
scratch and it talks a lot about you
know what we do as a society that
encourages that kind of behavior
and
what we do and how we help victims in
that situation
and so
one huge thing we have to work on is
building relationships between our
students
you know
um one thing that becky bailey dr becky
bailey also says is that
um willingness comes from connection and
so i'm a lot more likely to want to work
with you and get along with you if i
feel connected to you and feel like we
have something in common and so i think
it's the job of teachers at every level
to be building classroom community you
know within their school like i'm doing
this as intentionally as i am doing math
and literacy and social studies it is a
part of every day it is a part of every
subject that we are looking for ways um
to teach kids to see others with love
and empathy so i think if we could if we
could do that um you know at every level
our kids would be way better off and i
think that our bullying the levels of
bullying would go way down
yeah and it's a good point you know it
starts from some place um and and the
more you can build that early on the
the resilience against bullying so from
youtube new trap nation
asked what do you think about the way we
are learning during covet 19 and i'll
expand that question a little bit you
know what are you seeing in their
students you know
i think your students are very fortunate
to have you and you know you i think
you're doing it as well as anyone can
but are you seeing some gaps are you
worried about even your students and
what are your kind of concerns more
broadly uh for you know what what kids
are are going through right now
so i i'm troubled by some of the things
that that i see happening i think that
teachers administrators everyone is
doing their absolute best but there are
just requirements that we have to meet
from our states and their requirements
we have to meet federally i would like
to see some
some relaxation on some of those
requirements because in the situation of
virtual learning it is never going to
look just like school does when you're
in person and i think the expectations
that we put on families and on students
to have kids doing this synchronous
learning experience um six hours a day
from home it's it's not sustainable um
it's not feasible and and it's burning a
lot of people out students and families
and teachers all included in that what i
would like to see is some more
asynchronous opportunities so say
teachers upload videos of themselves
teaching or or lessons or activities and
families are able to complete those
within a week's time within the time
frame that works for them
yeah now what you're saying makes a ton
of sense i mean what we've been saying
when i'm asked the same question is we
have to i'd argue even pre-covered we're
probably trying to do too much but
especially during the time to try to
transplant six hours of in person with
six hours of video conference um it's
not it's gonna burn out the teachers
it's gonna burn out the students it's
gonna burn out the parents it's gonna
only add anxiety this is a time that
less is more uh so that you have more
space for for families uh to just take
care of everything else and and and not
and not atrophy what are these stan you
know is it just that the if the teachers
are feeling pressure from the state and
i guess then this the districts that hey
i gotta cover you know this many
standards in this many days and that
they're saying you have to have this
much face time you know in person i
think you know some in person you know
quote in person video conference makes
sense but yeah six hours is ridiculous
for for anybody
you know i i think that you know what
they're expecting is kind of six hours
of learning time and so some teachers
are really able to do you know a certain
amount of minutes um together online and
then some of the stuff on your own the
reality we're facing is though that some
students are at home alone or they don't
have someone helping keep them in a
routine or older siblings are the
caregiver
and so i think some teachers are feeling
pressure because of that to be more
present in those student lives but for
sure i think most of the pressure is
just coming from from regulations and
some schools just don't have enough
staff
to do anything except for let kids do
synchronous learning so i'm going to be
teaching in class if you're a remote
learner you're going to be watching me
teach in class and so that that's where
sort of that
that creates all of that time online
that it's just not healthy and not and
not good for kids to just sit for six
hours so what i hope is that we're gonna
find some more creative ways um to
engage online but i know that like the
hybrid models that are happening are
some of the most challenging
hmm
and we have time for maybe one last
question these conversations always go
faster than expected from facebook
manipushan asks how do students bond
interact with fellow classmates in the
virtual classroom environment our kids
are missing that healthy interaction
that they had in class with their
classmates
this is also tough you know i love
technology in some ways it makes our
world a lot smaller in some ways it
makes it a lot bigger you know i
i find the biggest most important thing
when connecting kids online is not just
giving them face time with me we do need
that individual face time and whole
class time but setting up small groups
and i've seen several teachers do this
and they do things like lunch buddies
and you know every day of the week
different groups of three or four
students will meet and have lunch
together then kids you know are more
likely and that's virtually kids are
more likely to open up in a smaller
group except especially our older ones
and with our younger ones they're a lot
more likely to be validated and heard
because they have lots of things to
share online and so i think that any
opportunity you have um
to decrease the size of the groups that
you're working with
you should definitely take because that
is something that will that will help
build those bonds
no i love that idea no we've talked
we've been throwing out the idea of
instead of having 60 minutes with
20 or 30 kids why not have 10 minutes
with five kids with six kids yeah yeah
increases the interactivity it fits into
what you're talking about around
attention span etc well we'll tab at the
we're all out of time time i mean i
could keep talking to you and i said i
don't say this you could watch the other
films of other people that we've been
you know you naturally exude this very
positive energy that i think
uh is is part of the reason uh that you
know you much deservedly are national
teacher of the year for 2020. do you
have any you know there's final messages
for either parents who are especially
parents of four or five-year-olds
struggling right now and teachers uh you
know who are struggling with their
regular lives and and trying to do
distance learning right now
for teachers the main thing that i would
say is use your voice right now okay we
have a big audience whether we like it
or not for the first time you know all
eyes are on school
and we need we need you we need the aids
we need the custodians and all the
support professionals to be using their
voice to talk to the people in their
district about what their needs are and
what their student needs are we need you
to advocate right now
and also hang in there because you're
doing your best and so give yourself
some grace and that's what i want to say
to families too this is a big
big big change in the way your lives
have operated and so just give yourself
some some grace do the best that you can
keep your kids on some kind of routine
and schedule but also give them a break
because this is hard for them to but
just hang in there you know i i always
say together we'll see it through and
and i think that's totally true and the
more that we work together um and
communicate and advocate the better off
that we'll be
wow well no great advice i feel less
anxious after you saying that so thank
you tabitha thank you so much and once
again congratulations on being national
teacher of the year much much deserved
thank you so much for having me
thank you well thanks everyone i think
you know y'all probably felt the same
you know positive energy that i felt uh
it's really inspiring to talk to a
teacher like tabitha uh thanks so much
for joining and i will see y'all let's
see the next uh conversation is going to
be next tuesday we're going to have lisa
damore who's a new york times columnist
specializing on kind of social emotional
and emotional well-being which is
obviously a very important topic some of
which we just touched on so i will see
you on tuesday on the homeroom live
stream see you then
you